a spring storm or a turning of the tide
whatever the ultimate toll covert 19 has
sparked a crisis that has engulfed us
all our health our finances our everyday
lives it's a moment that says the
Chancellor has brought the country
together in shared sacrifice but has it
in one sense we really are all in it
together never before has there been a
recession as affected quite so many
people across the country from all walks
of life but in other senses recessions
are I'm afraid inherently unequal some
people keep their jobs other people lose
them some people thrive other people
suffer that's just the nature of it
especially when you're facing an
economic storm the likes of which we've
never seen before and what we're
learning is that the impact of the virus
both on health and on the economy varies
enormous ly it's not even quite how
you'd assume yes cities have been more
affected in both respects but the death
rate here in Portsmouth has been below
the national average and there's less
evidence of a lock-down effect on
movement and social distancing here in
Lambeth in South London the death rate
is more than three times as high than in
Portsmouth one of the most badly
affected parts of the country so key
workers here like bus driver Pat a
particularly vulnerable we are not only
together we are we are the cleaners we
are the care workers where the nurses
where the bus driver we're doing all the
jobs that you know with it with the
general public we are I'm close with
them so we are gonna get it and it is
that concern that particular social and
ethnic groups are especially exposed
which is now becoming clear according to
figures from the Office of National
Statistics the impact of the virus is
being differently felt around the
country so the area with the least
deprivation has seen 25 deaths per
100,000 of the population the area with
the most deprivation has seen 55 deaths
per 100,000 it is about a 118 percent
difference between different areas and
it's not just about deprivation
different ethnic groups are facing
different outcomes as well according to
research from the Institute for Fiscal
Studies black Caribbean people are more
likely to die than many other ethnic
groups of this disease and also more
likely to be in key work in particular
they point out that a third of black
African workers
our key workers compared with only 10%
of white British workers the government
now says it's worried and looking into
these statistics of course this is only
part of the story
what about key workers who actually
can't work le from Surrey as a cleaner
or at least she was before the virus a
mother of three she's had to cancel all
her jobs simply to protect her clients
she and her husband are now trying to
get by on his income as a gardener and
working tax credits have worked at all
at the moment and just for the safety of
my clients I can't risk it we've had a
lot of sleepless nights panicking that
we won't be able to feed the kids and
like oh my god what's gonna happen
that's we're struggling through we've
got their back in Portsmouth Ashleigh a
supermarket worker counts herself as one
of the lucky ones she lives at home with
her parents and is now working nights
stacking shelves and picking food for
online orders to reduce the risk of
getting the disease there are measures
in place to protect us but of course it
is a little bit worrying like when maybe
customers aren't so that they don't
follow it as well as maybe they should
but you just kind of got to do the best
you can under circumstances as these
testimonies and the statistics that
underpin them mount up it's becoming
clearer about who is bearing most of the
risk of the disease and the economic
burden we are all in it together but
some more than others
Eddie Conway Sky News